♪ ♪ ♪
- Cet été sera le dernier pour
le club de golf Les Légendes,
situé dans le quartier
Saint-Luc, à Saint-Jean-sur-
Richelieu. Le terrain fermera
ses portes à la fin de la
saison, après 45 ans
d'existence. Les propriétaires
veulent utiliser le terrain pour
du développement immobilier. Le
golf est moins payant qu'avant.
MARC PERREAULT, p.-p. action. du
club de golf Les Légendes
- La relève n'est pas là.
Les gens ont d'autres intérêts
par rapport à des activités
de récréation ou sportives.
Ça fait que dans bien des
situations, et c'est le cas
dans le cas des Légendes,
ils ne pouvaient pas poursuivre
comme ça encore pendant 10 ans.
- Le projet prévoit la
construction d'environ
500 unités d'habitation
et la création d'un parc nature
de presque 15 hectares.
Mais le projet suscite de
l'inquiétude chez les riverains,
qui se sont regroupés au sein
de la Coalition Saint-Luc.
Bon nombre d'entre eux
s'opposent au changement
de zonage nécessaire
pour transformer le golf
en secteur résidentiel.
- Il y a une acceptabilité
sociale qui doit être prise
en considération. Et on a
l'impression qu'elle n'est pas
là du tout.
- Vous voyez ici ce qui est
extraordinaire, c'est qu'on a
toute une rangée d'arbres
naturels, des arbres qui sont
très vieux. Et si vous mettez
une maison ici, c'est clair
qu'où il y a des arbres,
c'est une rue.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour apaiser la contestation,
les promoteurs ont organisé
leur propre consultation
publique avec le concours
d'une firme de communications.
- C'est un début, une amorce
de dialogue. Maintenant,
il faut le poursuivre.
- Mais il n'y a pas que le club
des Légendes; il y a aussi
l'ancien golf des Boisés
de la Mairie, situé tout près.
Ce terrain a été racheté il y a
10 ans par les Baillargeon,
une famille d'industriels connue
à Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu.
Elle aussi espère un changement
de zonage. Une demande a été
faite plus tôt cette année.
Et dans un document de cour
déposé le mois dernier, les
Baillargeon prient le tribunal
d'ordonner à la municipalité
de traiter cette demande
immédiatemment.
Le porte-parole de la Coalition
Saint-Luc souhaite que ces
demandes de changement de zonage
soient rejetées. Il fait valoir
que les golfs et les boisés
qui les entourent ont une
certaine valeur écologique.
STÉPHANE LAMARRE, p.-p. et
admin., Coalition Saint-Luc
- Éviter les îlots de chaleur,
que la nature puisse reprendre
ses droits. Juste en arrière
de moi, on a quelques familles
de chevreuils qui sont venus
s'installer, on a des renards.
C'est un milieu qui est vraiment
fantastique pour tout ce côté-là
et qu'on a besoin
en milieu urbain.
- Ses préoccupations sont
partagées par le maire Alain
Laplante, qui s'oppose lui aussi
à ces projets immobiliers.
Il propose plutôt de racheter
les terrains, mais à la valeur
du rôle d'évaluation municipale,
et non à la valeur spéculative
d'un projet domiciliaire.
ALAIN LAPLANTE, maire,
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
- Évidemment, si nous changeons
le zonage, la valeur de ces
terrains-là explose, et on parle
là de dizaines et de dizaines
de millions de dollars.
Donc il est là, l'enjeu.
C'est de s'entendre sur le prix.
J'imagine que les citoyens ne
sont peut-être pas...
- Mais il n'est pas dit
qu'Alain Laplante sera
encore maire dans six mois.
Minoritaire au conseil de ville,
son mandat a été mouvementé.
En 2019, il a même été suspendu
trois mois pour une série
de manquements éthiques.
Andrée Bouchard se présente
contre lui aux élections.
Cette ex-présidente de la
commission scolaire des
Hautes-Rivières a réuni
de nombreux élus autour d'elle.
Son équipe est ouverte
au développement immobilier,
mais pas à n'importe quel prix.
ANDRÉE BOUCHARD, candidate à la
mairie, Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
- Mais j'aimerais vraiment
que les citoyens soient
en amont des projets.
Pas qu'on essaye de leur rentrer
dans la gorge des projets.
- Si elle est élue,
de nouvelles consultations
Et si les riverains en font
la demande, un référendum
sera tenu.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'avenir des golfs suscite
le débat depuis plusieurs années
à Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu.
Mais ce n'est pas la seule
municipalité à vivre
une telle situation.
Depuis 2010, 12 des 60 golfs
du Grand Montréal ont fermé
leurs portes pour laisser place,
en tout ou en partie,
à des projets de
développement immobilier.
Ici Jérôme Labbé,
Radio